so right over here we have one rational
expression being subtracted from another
rational expression i encourage you to
pause the video and see what this would
result in so actually do the subtraction
all right now let's do this together and
if we're subtracting two
rational expressions we'd like to have
them have the same denominator and they
clearly don't have the same denominator
and so we need to find a common
denominator and a common denominator is
one that is going to be divisible by
either of these and then we can multiply
them by by an appropriate expression or
a number so that it becomes the common
denominator so the easiest common
denominator i can think of especially
because these factors these two
expressions have no factors in common
would just be their product
so this is going to be equal to
so we could just multiply these two so
this is going to be actually let me do
let me do this one right over here in
magenta
so this is going to be equal to the
common denominator if i say if i want to
just multiply those two denominators for
this one i'll have my 8 x plus 7
and now i'm going to multiply it by 3x
plus 1.
i'm multiplying it by the other
denominator and i had negative 5x in the
numerator but if i'm going to multiply
the denominator by 3x plus 1 and i don't
want to change the value of the
expression we'll have to multiply the
numerator by 3x plus 1 as well notice 3x
plus 1 divided by 3x plus 1 is just 1
and you'd be left with what we started
with and from that we are going to
subtract
all of this now there's a couple of ways
you could think of the subtraction i
could just write a minus sign right over
here and do the same thing that i just
did
for the first for the first term or
another way to think about it and
actually for this particular case i like
thinking about it better this way is to
just add the negative of this and so if
i just multiplied negative 1 times this
expression i'd get negative 6 x 3 over
3x plus 1. if i had more terms up here
the numerator i would have to be careful
to distribute that negative sign but
here i only have one term so i just made
it negative and so i could say this is
going to be plus
and
and let me do this in a new color
this in green
our common denominator we already
established is just the product of our
two denominators
so it is going to be
8 x plus 7
times 3x plus 1.
now if we multiply the the denominator
here was 3x plus 1 we're multiplying it
by 8x plus 7 so that means we have to
multiply the numerator by 8x plus 7 as
well 8x plus 7
times
negative 6 x to the third power notice
8x plus 7 divided by 8x plus 7 is 1.
if you were to do that you would get
back to your original expression right
over here the negative 6x to the third
over 3x plus 1. and now we're ready to
add this is all going to be equal to
i'll write the denominator in white
so we have our common denominator 8x
plus 7 times 3x plus 1.
now in the magenta i would want to
distribute the negative 5x so negative
5x times positive 3x is
negative 15
x squared
and then negative 5x times 1 is minus 5x
and then in the green
i would have let's see i'll distribute
the negative 6x to the third power so
negative 6x to the third times
positive 8x is going to be negative 48
x to the fourth power
and then negative 6x third times
positive 7 is going to be negative
negative 42
x to the third
and
i think i'm done because there's no more
there's you know i only have one fourth
degree term one third degree term one
second degree term one first degree term
and that's it there's no more
simplification here some of you might
want to just write it
write it in descending degree order so
you could write it as negative
x to the fourth
minus 42 x to the third
minus 15 x squared
minus 5x
all of that over
8x plus 7
times 3x plus 1. but either way we are
all done and it looks like up here
yeah there's no nothing to factor out
these two are divisible by 5 these are
divisible by
but even if i were to factor that out
nothing over here down here no five or
six to factor out yeah so it looks like
we are all done